there are a few people that live in
Florida that are not happy with the
blueprint one of them is the views Anna
Navarro who also is a CNN contributor of
course can you what a resume she's on
The View on CNN it's a lot anyway how
did DeSantis win it's not because he did
everything that Floridians asked no it's
not because that it's because he gave
the system yeah I told you he was going
to win bigly but listen Ron DeSantis
barely won in 2018 by 35 000 votes by
the skin of his teeth against a black
Progressive little-known mayor from
Tallahassee Florida it didn't yesterday
he won by 20 percentage points why
because he gained the system because he
turned Florida into an unlevel playing
field they changed election laws making
it harder to vote by mail they paraded a
bunch of people black people that they
arrested for a voting fraud and paraded
them in front of national media he
created an election police
okay so Anna nonsense drivel and you're
literally basically the only person
saying that there were any Shenanigans
there's so many Shenanigans to really
talk about if you want to talk about
election irregularities and what's going
on in Arizona right now and you want to
talk about all of the early voting and
you want to talk about mail-in ballots
and you want to talk about drop boxes
and all of these things but nobody
nobody serious is saying that there was
anything wrong with the election here in
Florida so I'm not even going to give
her uh much of that but that he gained
the system it's just not right what he
did was he tightened the rules so that
everyone actually had to have an ID to
vote and most people did show up and
then by the way I mentioned it last week
when the hurricane hit he did loosen
some of the mail-in ballot stuff and
early stuff so that people would be able
to vote because they were dealing with
their own tragedies I mean houses that
were gone and all sorts of stuff he did
nothing racist they're not coming for
the gays here it's all just nonsense